hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm jeremy
welcome to raisins to see where we're
gonna give you reasons to see or maybe
not to see transformers age of
extinction let's hang out
Autobots who we saw transformers age of
extinction I did not fall asleep this
time I was bored as [ __ ] during the
first one I fell asleep for most of the
second one and I think I didn't catch
any of the third one but I was actually
right I like this one I mean there's
that it's still like not the most
improved story or characters whatever
yeah but the action was still
entertaining us on an iMac since totally
worth watch on iMac I enjoyed it too
besides me maybe falling asleep it's a
long [ __ ] movie it's like it's ours in
45 minutes I think yeah I've just and
it's like most of it is non-stop
explosions yeah bullet time and slow
motion like everything yeah it was like
it was crazy mayhem but I thought the
action in visual effects they improved
it actually you could see what's going
on a lot more and it just looks more
realistic and there's some badass
transformer [ __ ] like the [ __ ] UH the
main villain with a gun yeah I think
that was that was pretty silly yeah that
was cool and I kind of like the plot of
it too you know like they're wiping out
the Transformers it kind of makes sense
actually and then you know Frasier is
working with the bad guys I think I
cared more about Mark Wahlberg than I
did Shia LaBeouf a Megan Fox I agree I
felt more passionate with Mark Wahlberg
it's it more relatable in them like two
teenagers who are in love yeah yeah it
was cool although there were some issues
I had with the writing of Mark
Wahlberg's character okay first off the
the the funny employee he has yes yeah
and then he gets killed I was a little
bummed out that he got killed yeah in
the way he got killed
yeah I mean kind of cool but it still
you just look like a role
I was live long enough that he died but
then something part of me was like Marc
Luber doesn't feel bad about this at all
what else his faux sympathy Jo killed
the only thing was just he's gone all
your fault against you really wanted
this truck yeah you kind of like [ __ ]
over your whole family and everything
and just some like like the first like
hour and a half of his dialogue was him
telling her his daughter's boy like his
relationship with his daughter was like
I'm strict you can't do anything yeah
and then the boyfriend was like hey
Lucky Charms cut it out yeah hi you
can't be around my guys like dude yeah
that's a new dialog like when when
Optimus Prime
bust out of the barn and then they start
driving away cuz the boyfriend oh yeah
that's a professional racecar driver
Hussam
rally driver rally driver yeah like I I
was like this is ridiculous why's Mark
Wahlberg getting on this guy's ass right
now not a concern and at the same time
you saved your [ __ ] ass beautiful for
this guy
one of my friends doesn't enjoy him in
films okay because he told me a lot of
times he just seems like he's always out
of breath and now that I think of all
the movies he's been in there's another
part where he's just like a puppet
that's true like I mean you know he's
always running in every single movie
that I've ever known to see him in but
not this his character is pretty cool I
mean you know the buff dad buff farmer
the inventor yeah invented all types a
weird but we really blew my mind was
like he's an inventor if he can help
repair a transformer but yet he's so
broken can invent invention that was
bringing beer to the guy yeah
um I really think that was like just
big-ass conditioned air moving around he
can he can totally repair haughtiness
Brian but he can't [ __ ] build a tiny
ass machine yes
exactly so broke over there oh yeah like
Mark Wahlberg though I thought it was
cool when you've like got the gun and
stuff like that oh it looks like a halo
gun I got six excited I'm like oh my god
halo in real life with transformers it
was a lot of halo like beam going on in
this one yeah even the main bad guy -
yeah straight up it was like a halo gun
actually you're right about them right
it's sore but it's not yeah that was
[ __ ] cool though hey yeah Marc Bohan
was pretty [ __ ] cool yeah but the
daughter um she's [ __ ] hot as hell
but no doubt about that pretty bad
actress though like yeah kind of
annoying Michael Bay cast people
talented actor knows just how they look
yeah they look good on a camera of
putting them in but it's like okay she's
in short shorts the whole [ __ ] movie
yeah she is gorgeous to look at but at
the same time it was like dude dad dad
boyfriends yeah meet him you can't let
me do anything she's like and the
dinobots they're pretty [ __ ] cool
Dinobots I love it this is almost a
three-hour film and they come in very
late into the film and I I spent a good
like our wandering in the previous most
of the spots yes I got disease Dinobots
and then you're like watching this like
really lengthy plot go on and you're
like what yeah well you're the Dinobots
gonna show yeah I get why he was
fighting them at first though Optimus
Prime uh ya know cuz he said like they
were look at the legends you know above
him yeah and I think I think that's I
think I woke up right when he starts
like oh [ __ ]
here no but um and all of a sudden they
just kind of like hey well now these are
the legends that are gonna help us but I
can easily do now the way they transform
is pretty tight - yeah I know that the
transforming in this was really [ __ ]
cool like the one like they've been
keeping it one shot where it's like
obviously a real car that they turn into
a robot and you're like whoa and when
they and they turned into Dinobots that
was pretty [ __ ] sweet they were they
were pretty cool I like the Dinobots a
lot actually yeah fire breath
I like Stanley Tucci in this movie I
thought he was fun and I liked how he
started off as like bad guy but then
turned into a good guy and like that
transition made sense to me he transform
right well I didn't quite by was the
ending when like Mark Wahlberg hugs em
yeah I'm like this guy kind of caused
all this [ __ ] just cuz he's gonna get a
home like dude this guy was you way more
than oh well yeah it almost died in the
past two days like many times yeah but
no say I teach you he was a lot of fun
to watch like there's some pointless
scenes though like yeah once yeah I like
what Stanley teach you when he's in the
elevator and he's like laughing
hysterically during a sterically but
that scene was kind of pointless mm-hmm
well you know it's like the bad guys are
chasing him and like dudes really need
bad guys chasing this guy right yeah and
then the asian girl shows up and she
kicks ass and the random guy in the
elevator because he's Asian yeah kind of
cool but not necessary to have in the
film yeah and then Stanley almost trying
to make out with the asian chick yeah
another friend of romance coming along I
was I thought it was a little bit more
it got like the CIA plot which is fine
and then you got the bad guys or they're
working with and then suddenly they're
like look we can make a chart back yeah
let's call it
make it your own yeah let's go Megatron
in the battles now and then we'll make
it out of the way let's bring the other
bad guys back and then we'll have humans
I mean it was like the last hour was
just like crazy this had nowhere to
follow yeah I was too is a little too
much man a lot of debris there was just
debris the entire movie I felt I was
getting like cut with debris okay look
at the end of the day you know it's like
you're getting into when you watch this
goddamn movie yeah transformer dad you
know anything you're not gonna get in
there for the story you're going in
there for like the crazy action and the
visual effects there's only so much
detail you can go into on that [ __ ] it's
just no it's [ __ ] awesome and they
don't spoil all the best stuff in the
trailers yeah it's like they actually
have like a lot of great surprise action
scenes and stuff like that and it is
very entertaining and stuff and I
believe Mark Wahlberg more as someone
who's fighting then Shia LaBeouf so
forth I'm not I didn't like the first
three transformers but I can honestly
say like yeah there's a lot about this
movie that's not good but I thought it
was fun and I thought there was some
stuff I was like that's really badass
yeah especially because the visual
effects greatly improved this time
around it did hey I love the visual
effects nose it is beautiful to look at
at times and like I actually gave a [ __ ]
about Optimus Prime in this one yeah you
felt like he had heart yeah exactly
oh yes hard with this with his other
Autobots but this one you're like he
actually cares about the humans in a
different way because he's gonna pissed
off at the humans like yeah you know
it's like I [ __ ] saved your ass yeah
and now you guys just won nothing but to
kill me the beginning scene he was like
evil he says he doesn't kill ya the
opening scene when he comes out it was
like Optimus I thought it was I thought
it was a blast and I highly recommend
watching in the theaters yep cuz yeah
you're gonna have a good time I mean
they could use a little bit more comedy
but it's it's fun it's very fun so
Jeremy what are some reasons to see you
think visual effects visual effects
visual effects in action that probably
have to be the first reason Marky Mark's
biceps Marky Mark's biceps there were
some good yet some of his performance
yeah he's better yeah he's good
Emily the daughter the hot blonde hot
she's gonna look at that actress but
good to look at yep Dinobots and I'm the
Dinobots pretty cool [ __ ] cool
stanley tucci probably the best actor in
the entire a is the best actor
I even like Kelsey Grammer actually yeah
I believed him you know come off of like
a comedy show like Frasier and stuff and
then you're like watching okay yeah he's
a good bad guy good human bad guy
agreed all right guys check it out our
review for transformers age of
extinction why don't you go ahead scroll
that comment box below and tell me us
tell us what uh transformer if you want
to see more episodes of reason to see
click this link right here yeah and
Jeremy he he's starting up a channel
it's gonna be like you know Allah is a
great [ __ ] dancer seriously it's like
it's mind-blowing topic the popular
right popping yeah it's the craziest
[ __ ] pop all types of stuff see them
work out bids and stuff show me your
biceps from that Marky Mark myself Marky
Mark biceps all right he wants me gonna
show the right one ready for this
channel and as always if you want to get
updated every time one of our views or
videos is out subscribe yeah man that
was a cool movie I would watch that I
don't know maybe I'll forget about it
actually yeah I'll wait till yeah DVD
yeah and bus I just I would really like
it if they just improve the characters a
little bit like the humans and the
Transformers I agree this is it really
that much to ask for after four movies
like a darker transformers yeah making
darker transformers me he's really
badass and cool but I will say like ah
it was cool about this one was it felt
fresh it did you know like it was none
of the old characters or it in yeah and
it just it does have us because of the
characters are so different the dynamics
it does have a different vibe about it
you know it's kind of like a family vibe
going on that's true so I really do I
did appreciate that and
yeah I was cool I would love to be a
transformer I wish I was even - I would
transform right there yeah it'll be my
spotlight you ready for this to be so
dope what would it turn into
I'll do anything you want